I'd like to say the hardest thing we did
was probably the road trip actually that
was like that was hard that was that was
intense just because our filming
schedule was so intense and our schedule
was so intense
um and uh me and Manu shared a room like
a few days uh Emmanuel who is uhara who
is uh the person who helped film our
road trip special shout out uh we should
never share a room together because we
have our own personal schedule when it
comes to the morning I am taking a
shower and I'm taking a shower for as
long as I need to take a shower and he
has the same kind of philosophy really
are you huh how dirty are you sometimes
you know sometimes are you washing away
your sins sometimes sometimes you just
need a certain amount of time just to
like wake like mentally prep for the day
let's get a bathtub what a bathtub it's
called coffee
did you sit in the bathtub it's like
literally the shower but better but it's
I don't I don't wake up in the bath I
fall asleep in the Box no yeah I love
starting my morning in the bath because
then I you know you put it you watch
YouTube or something you just chill
getting ready normally normally a bath
to me has always been like if I'm gonna
take a bath it's like the end of the day
no no I know it's like probably wasteful
but I mean maybe I might even be in the
bathroom like 10 minutes I guess I
although
yeah although why why am I having my
equating time spent in math equals less
waste of water like
it doesn't [ __ ] matter if you think
about it but yeah um I yeah normally
I'll I'll shower I do the Japanese thing
I don't I really like it shower first
shower first yeah get all the the
dirtiness off your body whatever and
then go in the bathroom
using water for showers
that is the Japanese that is the
Japanese yeah you wash off like I'm not
not crazy with it it's like two minutes
time yeah let me just turn it on get wet
and then do all the Soaps yeah turn it
back on rinse I don't understand it's
just for you Africa
I know it's a waste of water but like
I've never understood people who just go
in the bath I'm like you're just you're
sitting in your own field
um are you are you I sometimes like
without washing your body off first
Sometimes I will just go in the bath
just for like I just need to like brain
reset and for me I don't know it helps
me relax a lot I might just jump in it
for 15 minutes I can't relax knowing the
fact that I haven't washed my body and
I'm sitting in water that is if it's
just like water like I understand for
communal baths because obviously you're
like sharing above so yes you wash off
before if it's just like my own bar yeah
it's just me yeah yeah it's just the
water's like you're not hopefully not
that dirty yeah I'm really muddy yeah
yeah I know that I'm not like I'm not
like in a Rugrats episode
sometimes I just wake up and I'm feeling
extremely lazy to the point where I'm
like I do not want to stand up I want to
sit in this bath and wake up that's what
I'll do like especially if I wasn't like
if I wasn't sweating a lot like a warm
bath right with a hot bath yeah it just
makes me sleepy I'm just not a bath guy
I think I [ __ ] love bats man I feel
like it it's like a third eye don't like
it you've like reached a new chakra
level I feel like that's me I feel like
that's me but with showers I can spend
like so much time in the shower but I
feel like it's because I need that like
sensation of like water just hitting my
head or something
talk about being in the shower the whole
time I just I literally just picture you
against the wall like
[Music]
I don't know why Rick waiting for a
dream stuff yeah just like just like the
movie protag [ __ ] before you're about to
like I don't know like take over a
building or something I wish I looked I
wish I looked that cool I'm just like
not most of the time I'm just standing
in one place and just like having a
[ __ ] existential crisis or something
you know I'm just like where did I go
[Laughter]
I think the most Opie [ __ ] in the bath
is a window
say it right now a window window in the
bath is so Opie yeah
I missed it so much I realized in the UK
we have Windows not bathrooms and I
realized after living in Japan how much
I missed that oh you don't know
in the well in my house yeah yeah I do
oh you do but my previous place in most
Japanese houses don't yeah because
they're like it's kind of like its own
room yeah yeah I realized some privacy I
think I think that also might be why I
like this bath so much is that the
window is literally right there the bath
let's get a bunch of sunlight waking up
it's so [ __ ] nice yeah yeah yeah
um unfortunately I'm on the ground
levels uh window doesn't really do it I
already have Windows oh yeah otherwise
my neighbors would see my dick so yeah
that's uh that's for sure yeah yeah no
windows windows in the bathrooms I wish
Japan could have had it more but I get
it because a lot of houses are like like
this close to each other yeah so what
would a window do yeah sure yeah [ __ ] I
love it so much yeah I don't know like I
like I understand why [ __ ] monks need
to meditate under a [ __ ] waterfall
you know there's just some something
calming about the feeling of water just
gushing over your head that just yeah
it's like a little muscle and it's just
like you know I I need a certain amount
of time in the shower every morning just
to be like okay my brain brain wake up
brain you're gonna do this you're gonna
do actually gonna do wine if I get out
too early
then my brain just it just feels like my
brain hasn't properly started yet my my
favorite [ __ ] thing is at the
hairdressers in Japan after they like
cut your hair or dye your hair or
whatever and then put you into that like
shower thing yeah back and then it's
like that it's just like that perfectly
pressurized shower that just
concentrates on certain parts
do we all agree that hot tubs are met
yes
yeah okay just making sure I've I've
I've never thought about it but you know
being from like the middle of nowhere in
in the UK you know I always thought hot
tubs were like because you'd see them
all the time on like American stuff hot
tubs hot tubs the coolest [ __ ] and I
always thought it was really [ __ ]
awesome and the first few times I really
think I really liked it but now I kind
of think they're a bit [ __ ] not that
we've had onsens I'm like how can you go
back to hot tub hot tubs are always like
and they never work properly and when
they do the Jets like way too [ __ ]
powerful and you can only felt like
there's always more people it depends
like are you are you just sitting in the
hot tub you have to be drinking right oh
yeah you have to be drinking but like a
lot of the times like either no one
wants to go in the hot tub or way too
many people want to go in the hot tubs
yeah and the water like you know the I
swear to God they're like the most
finicky things to get working um it's
it's a really weird thing because hot
tubs have this like really cool image of
being like yeah they do yeah I'm
partying I've got the girls around me
[ __ ] you know look at me got drinking
champagne got some Dom Perignon you know
open that [ __ ] up but then when you
actually have a hot top because I think
it's really tight like that in our La
Airbnb where we filmed where we spent
like three weeks in yeah I found a bunch
of episodes in did so much here we had a
hot tub there I remember going there on
the first day and be like yeah I'm gonna
use this hot tub we never even never use
them never even came close we never took
the covers off it's a mid bath dude
that's like what it is it's like a
mid-back I'm like where's the Onsen yeah
because because the thing the thing is
okay let's say you want to go to like
you're you're at a party right and
there's a hot tub in there
it's such a [ __ ] hassle just to like
change it to swimming shorts right yeah
and it's once you and once you get in
the hot tub then there's going to be a
point where you want to go out and it's
just such a [ __ ] hassle to be in this
hot tub you're at a party and you're
like [ __ ] I'm wet now like I I gotta
deal with this [ __ ] you know I have to
walk all the way to get a towel yeah dry
myself off and then you have to go
upstairs get changed you smell like pool
water yeah yeah you smell like pool
water and you're like hair's all messy
and stuff now and you're like this is
not what I want to do in like a social
situation you know I'd rather just chill
and just uh talk like any other party
yeah but Sean is a God too I love saunas
so much I think someone's like the best
thing ever I'm just like I'm indifferent
to someone yeah I think actually no I
hate someone else but what why I just
watched Southeast Asian yeah I just
can't I just can't stand the heat let's
just go outside yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah why would you need a
sauna saunas are so good though
so amazing after it it's it's just like
too hot for me same with
is that
the point of saunas is that it's really
really hot yeah why they call it a sauna
I know she just like you're just like
it's too hot
I don't like the pool it's everywhere
I don't like saunas because
you're trying to move in there you were
in there for like five minutes and you
get out it's just not a pleasant
experience for me I don't know what is
this a weird thing I go in a really
really hot room and I'm like it's really
really hot and I don't feel nice right
now most people I find that don't like
it are the ones who don't want to go in
the cold water
why would you want to oh man it feels
amazing it feels so good when you when
you actually do it it's I genuinely I I
there are a few Sensations on Earth that
make me feel as like satisfied as going
in the sauna going in the [ __ ] ice
ass cold bath they're going back in the
sauna bro people did the [ __ ] ice
bucket challenge because it was a
charity event you know people didn't do
it because it was a pleasant experience
you know no that's that's why people do
when they get off and they're like oh
this is a yard
all the Europeans are like yes Connor
yes I'm telling you this shit's amazing
also it's very good for you no that's
the thing it's like that's why I'm
indifferental it's like I don't if I had
the choice to go into it or if I had
didn't have to go into it then I won't
go into it but I know that the health
benefits I shall not convince Chris to
do it I convinced Chris to get in the
course can you believe that in the cold
war in the cold bath I convinced him to
get in it how much did you pay him
[Music]
I mean obviously you guys can pretty
tell that Chris it does if Chris doesn't
want to do something it's very hard to
convince him yeah and and anything that
makes me not comfortable he won't do I I
one time I was like you should come in
the cold there and I went in and I was
like I was like dying I was like I was
like yeah it's on my bed come in so he
put his like foot and he went
and I was like no no
people put your dick in it'll be fine